the the Chinese balloon which I think
was very badly mishandled by the Biden
Administration is significant in its own
right the people theorize that one
reason they're interested in balloon
surveillance over the United States is
that in the event of War people have
spoken for a long time about China's
anti-satellite program being designed to
take out American eyes in the sky so
they would expect we would then do the
same to theirs and balloon surveillance
is a substitute a poor substitute I
think but something to look at so this
this should be this balloon should be a
wake-up call for people in the United
States and Europe and elsewhere who
don't think China is a threat in the
21st century in in my view China is the
existential threat in the 21st century